[음악]
네. 네, 안녕하세요. 빌사남입니다.
제가 오늘 두바이에 왔습니다. 두바이
인구가 한 350만 명 정도 됩니다.
그리고 여기 사는 사람 대부분은 다
외국인들이 많이 거주하고 있어요.
거의 한 85% 90% 정도는
외국인이 거주하고 있고 그리고
두바이의 장점이 되게 많은데 그거는
제가 차 영상을 찍으면서 여러분들한테
설명드리도록 하겠습니다. 오늘 일정은
아부다비를 가서 거기 협력사를 좀
만나서 부동산 투어를 할 계획입니다.
네. 지금 아부다비를 가려고
이동하려고 차에 타 있습니다.
아부다비 그 현지에서 그 부동산을
운영하시는 분을 좀 만나뵙기로
했어요. 만나서 뭐 아부이 지금 뭐
부동산 상황이라든지 그리고 뭐 이렇게
궁금한 것들도 많아서 한번 좀 직접
물어볼
예정입니다. 네. 지금 아브다비 현지
부동산에 좀 찾아왔는데 지금 아부다비
부동산 사항이 좀 어떤지 좀 설명해
주신다고 하는데 그 설명을 들으러
[음악]
왔습니다. 네. 4네시간 정도 회의를
했는데 일단은 좀 새로운 사실을 좀
많이 알게 됐고 그리고 이제
한국이랑은 조금 다른 부분 또 있는
거 같아서 제가 일단이 내용을 좀 잘
정리해 가지고 이따가 자세하게 좀
설명을 다시 드리도록 하겠습니다.
그리고 같이 온 김에 그 M 체결도
좀 했거든요. 그래서 나중에 이제 뭐
아부다비라든지 두바이에 부동산에 관심
있다라고 하시면은 뭐 여기 리맥스
측에 연락 주시면은 좋을 것
같습니다. 네. 그래서 제가 지금
우리나라로 치면은 모델 하우스에 좀
와 있는데 사실 여기 지금 왔는데 뭐
2027년에 완공된다라고 하는데 지금
아무것도 없긴 하거든요. 사실 지금
거의 시간이 얼마 안 남았는데 뭐
그때까지 다 중공이 된다라고 합니다.
어 정말 되게 빠른 속도로 신축을
하는 거 같은데 여기 모델 하우스
되게 잘 돼 있어요. 네. 그래서
지금 사람들도 많이 있는 거 같고
그래서 좀 자세하게 설명 좀
들어보도록 하겠습니다. 다 해놓 거고
여기도 전부 다 약간 멀지 아부다비는
백진 상태에서 말하는 대로 만들어지는
것 같습니다. 바다 근처 위주로
둘러싸인 이곳은 호다이 리아트라는
아일랜드인데요. 이곳에서 나와 F스트
힐이라는 곳에는 40억부터 시작해
지대가 높을수록 200억까지 가는 거
같습니다. 노른자 땅이라 개발 방식에
따라 아부다비 랜드마크가 될 수도
있을 것 같습니다. 네. 이게 지금
말씀하신 것처럼 제일 비싼 거 같은데
쪽에 차량을 대기를 했다가 이쪽으로
올라오는 거 같고 그리고 지금 이렇게
세 개층 돼 있고 마지막 루프탑에는
뭐 룸을 만들 수 있다라고 하네요.
가은 형식으로도 되고 엄청 진짜 이거
방이 몇 개야?
[음악]
아, 여기 진짜 엄청 커요.이 지금
가격이 뭐 6억 8천 뭐이 정도
수준이라고 하는데 진짜 그 가격
대비해서 진짜 엄청 좋은 거 같아요.
불과 만들어진지 얼마 되지도 않았는데
진짜 여기 있는 놀라운게 공사가 되게
빨리 합니다. 그 여기 인근에 살고
계시는 그런 노동력을 이용해 가지고
되게 뚝딱뚝딱 짓는다 그래요. 진짜
완전 사막귀였던 곳을 이렇게 만든
건데 너무 좋은데요.
야, 이게 말이 되나? 너무 좋다
여기. 와, 이거 수영장이 와. 이야
이게 지금 좌측에 보면 인공빛을
만들어
놨어요. 정말 말하는 대로 이루어질
정도로 어 진짜 놀라운데요. 완벽한
해변가 같습니다. 우측에 있는 쪽도
여기 앞에 이제 인공 미치를 만들어
놓려고 지금 하고 있는데 와 근데
이게 진짜 말이 안 돼요.이 지금
어떻게 완전 해벽감 같은데요? 그래서
여기는 입주민만 사용할 수 있다라고
합니다. 그래서 제가 만약에 여기
거주하고 있으면 여기 진짜 맨날 올
거 같아요. 진 대박입니다,
[음악]
여러분. 네. 그래서 여기가 두바이
힐즈라는 곳인데 그 두바이랑 아브비
그 중간에 있어요. 그래 가지고
여기는 한 40억 정도의 할
예정이라고 하고 여기로 갈수록 이제
가격이 계속 높아져서 여기는 무려
한억 정도의 어 분양을 한다라고
합니다. 와 진짜 너무 좋은데요.
지금
개인적으로는 저기 그 크릭 있는
쪽보다는 저는 이제 가족이니까네
이쪽에 좀 더 선호할 것 같습니다.
네. 그래서 지금이 말을 해서 여기
지금 크릭 타워 쪽을 이제
개발한다라고 하는데 크릭 타워가 지금
브루즈 알리파가 한 828m인데
그거보다 높게 지는다고 합니다.
예전에 막 인터넷 기사로 돌았던게 뭐
1,300m까지 지울 거다라고 뭐
그런 기사도 나오긴 했었는데 뭐
정확하게 몇 미터인지 안 나와
있습니다. 근데 아마 이제 세 개에서
가장 높은 타워가 되지 않을까
싶습니다. 브루즈알리파도 828m고
아마 그거보다 높게 지으면 거의
롯데타워에 두 배일 거 같아요. 네.
그래서 그 정도로 되게 높은 건물이
어 들어설 예정입니다. 그 지금 저기
작게 보이는 저 건물이 한 78층
정도 된대요. 네. 그래서 여러분들
크기가 가음이 좀 되시나요? 네.
저게 지금 78층인데 되게 작게
보입니다. 저도 여기 직접 와서
보지만 진짜 어마어마합니다. 규모가
이게 대규모 프로젝트를 하기에 되게
좋은 거 같습니다. 지금 뭐 이마르가
이렇게 좀 개발을 먼저 하면 그
자산가들한테 약간 성분양식으로 하나
봐요. 약간 그분들이 빨리 매입할 수
있게 하고 그래서 실질적으로 여기에
매입하기에는 좀 쉽진 않은 거 같아.
그래서 만약에 이제 그분들한테 다
판매를 했는데 판매가 안 되면 이제
남는 거를 살 수 있는 기회가 있긴
하는데 뭐 나오기 전에 다 팔린다라고
합니다. 그래서 그 정도로 어 정말
인기가 많은 거 같아요. 만약에이
지금 크릭 타워가 지어지고 하면은
궁금하네요. 이거 지금 몇 년 뒤에
한번 다시 와서 한번 좀 찍어 보면
좋을 거 같아요.
네. 여기 지금 쇼룸에 왔는데 일단
내부는 여러분들 아시는 그 안도
다다오 아시죠? 네. 그 그분이 이제
디자인을 했다라고 합니다. 아까 이제
설명해 주시는 분한테 원래 이제 전에
안도다오가 그 복싱 출신이거든요. 그
말씀드리니까 되게 놀라시더라고요.
네. 아무튼 일단 외부는 아르마니가
이제 설계를 했다라고 해요. 되게
감각이 있고 어 되게 유니크한 그런
장소를 만든 거 같습니다. 팜에
만드는 거예요. 예. 밤에 이거를
만들어서 하는데 와 여기 진짜 야
이거 무슨 명품 명품 매장 같은데요?
약간 풀라다 느낌. 어, 근데 이거
지금 쇼룸처럼 어, 이렇게 똑같이
되진 않는다라고 하고 집마다 다 좀
다르게 만들어질 예정이라고 합니다.
와, 여기
안에도 되게 깔끔하고 제 이렇게 손을
못
대겠어요. 어, 되게 유명한 여기
이제 독일 업체에서 만들었다라고
합니다. 이게 사실 저도 이제 국내
분양하는 곳들가 보면은 조금 약간 그
이런 얘기 하긴 좀 그렇지만 조금
뭐이 훌륭한데도 있지만 조금 이제 싼
자재를 쓰는 곳들도 많은데 여기는
그냥 하나하나가 엄청 비싼 제가
정확히 모르겠지만 엄청 비싼 가구들이
많이 있는 거 같습니다. 여기 뷰가
너무 좋을 것 같아요. 이게 실제로
팜에 이렇게 지어 놓으면 어 정말
멋지게 지어지지 않을까 싶습니다.
그리고 설계를 좀 봤는데 약간
아치형으로 돼 있더라고요. 그래서
이쪽은 브루즈 할리파 보이고 그다음에
이쪽에는 바다 뷰를 볼 수 있는 어
그런 공간이 있다라고 하는데이 색깔이
좀 다르다라고 합니다. 좌측 편이랑
우측 편이랑 그것도 좀 되게 신기한
거 같고 보통 거기 건물들이 되게
높은 건물들이 많은데 여기서 만드는
곳 같은 경우에는 그렇게 건물 층은
높지 않다라고 합니다. 궁금하네요.